les écoles de téléphoner mais alors si
vous êtes un membre ou à barrick gold
abx alors non je vais appeler j'ai
appelé rappelé la vie on veut aller aux
arts l'herbe et la paix c'est rohff
alors venu taper dans sa peine dans un
instant oui oui raccrocher parce que
ouais alors on me dit qu on le fait dans
un instant c'est bien le cas de
transition alors donc je vais appeler
flavie flament vous leur posez donc de 2
est ce que je pourrais jouer le rôle de
médiateur et si vous voulez mais déjà
déjà il faut qu'elle ne savait vraiment
qu'est ce que tu as dispositif médical
convient aussi pour les douleurs dans
les jambes
google sa messagerie c'est bien
évidemment ça ne gênera hasan psychiatre
sabawi va pas bloquer la vue que c'est
vous la va pas répond je les aimais
choix oui fabrice et c'est benji est ce
qu'on ne pourrait pas se faire un petit
dîner prochainement voilà pour échanger
un peu sur le voilà sur le sur le sur la
vie sur la vie voilà alors faites moi
cet attelage de 300 au revoir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très bien j'ai fait j'ai fait ça j'ai
fait sa faute j'ai fait ça bon essayer
une autre ex non parce que là avec un
message pas alors dans l'eure allô allô
allô allô oui c'est mon amour gb coûte
mais cultivent leur travail et la chérie
tu as écouté les ferries les jus pour le
prévenu n'est qu'à 20 ans serait pas là
quand tu rentres mon amour tu te dis
nike pourrait croire alors le kilo de
penser que non non non non fournier je
rentre à 21h30 pas 20 ans mais là on est
mort donc il ya un terreau fois je me
prépare à tout voir de tels volumes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors mon amour ne te méprends pas
c'était pour faire un test pour faire le
test du poste voir si ça pouvait
fonctionner comme j'ai fait un appel
c'est pas vrai mais il y va par il avait
pas entendu elle a raccroché
l'histoire donc la nouvelle émission une
bonne émission ce soit
normalement au point aux plongeurs
suisses et les plus là je rappelle
qu'elle chante on peut perdre une de
perdue
[Applaudissements]
je sévis et vous je vous encourage en
ont alors ressaisissez vous allez à
l'écouté je vais donc leur entrée chez
moi dans pas longtemps